alex is in North Carolina
Merry Christmas Alex Merry Christmas
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
so I hit the ground running on baby step
2 this is the first time we've ever
really had any significant debt but I am
getting a settlement from an auto
accident earlier this year and I'm
trying to figure out because my car
right now
like a good girl is a piece of junk but
it runs doesn't qualify for uber so I'm
wondering if I should take some of that
funds to do a rideshare to get more
money in the long run instead of just
throwing it all at the debt okay and so
the car that you currently are driving
is worth what about two grand and what
would it cost to get a car that
qualifies for uber about five is what
I'm looking at cuz it used to be within
the last ten years and in good standing
repair insider
so it's three thousand dollar spread
mm-hmm how much can you make driving
over I do have two kids so I'd only be
able to do it once or twice a week so
the income I'm not sure on I just know
it's a opportunity to make money okay
but if it's a dollar it would take you
3,000 rides and it wouldn't make much
sense if it's a thousand dollars thank
you three rides and then make a ton of
sense it's not either one of those two
right right okay so that's how you need
to analyze this and so what I would do
is have some conversations with some of
the ride-sharing folks uber or lyft or
whoever you're talking about and figure
out what you would make on in your
particular area driving two nights a
week and divide that into three thousand
and if you can get your money back in a
couple of months yeah that's probably
okay just from then on you're adding to
the equation to get out of debt but if
it's gonna take you two years to break
even on this no I wouldn't fool with it
you see how I'm doing um no that makes
perfect sense
the follow-up to that and I know the
baby steps you start with the smallest
does go to largest kind of get that that
motivation in that win my concern is if
I clear the credit card debt because I
could and we'd only have the student
loan left that my husband who's Steve
Ramsey ish isn't going to get that sense
of motivation I can't help you modify
our formula that works I can help you
modify your husband yeah but I mean
that's the problem it's not the you
can't you can't half but do something
and figure out a way that that's going
to work and so you know and I think
that's something you and him are gonna
have to talk about and I would not buy
the uber car unless he you've gotten him
on board and no I'm not gonna modify
this the reason is it doesn't work honey
doesn't work what works is the two of
you working together on stuff couples
that do not work together on money have
a almost zero probability of winning
with money tada
all the data that we have of all the
millionaire's of all the people getting
out of debt almost never do we find
someone dragging a spouse along where
they actually win and have success
spouses are just too heavy to drag along